vous
non
c'est l'histoire d'une esclave
nanet racontée par les collégiens de
bourbeau bourbon tout un symbole que de
porter ce nom qui fait justement
référence à cette période sombre de
l'histoire de notre île
l'un est qu'eric exhumé des archives qui
devient l'héroïne d'une pièce de théâtre
où se mêlent fiction et réalité
780 mairie est déserte
puis à sannois elle est passée chez mon
père quand je me suis marié
la faisait partie de ma
roger est née d'abord dans le cadre du
concours sur les esclavages les traites
et d'abolition donc pour cours
ce qui est proposé tous les ans par le
rectorat
on a commencé à travailler dans ce
contexte là et très vite on bon au delà
de la production qu'on a pu proposer on
a voulu aller plus loin et proposer une
vraie pièce de théâtre en tout cas
des scènes de pièces de théâtre un
travail de recherche qui a permis
d'abord de comprendre une période
et puis de l'identifier un personnage
pour enfin le mettre en scène
c'est ensuite le théâtre qui reprend ses
droits et d'apprentissage même difficile
surprend comment ces jeunes collégiens
ont pu si facilement retenir tous ces
textes faire abstraction du trac et
surtout se glisser complexe main dans le
rôle mon travail ça a été vraiment de
deux mètres au plateau des élèves qui
avaient jamais
jamais fait de théâtre donc il a fallu
faire des exercices d'échauffement des
exercices sur la voie qu'il faudrait
continuer d'ailleurs parce que d'abord
c'est un travail de tous les jours un
certain comédiens le dirait bien et
ensuite parce qu'ils sont jeunes donc il
y met beaucoup de volonté mais en même
temps voilà ils ont ils ont des
faiblesses dont qu'on a on a utilisé des
petits micros en plus il joue dans des
conditions qui sont pas simple parce
qu'il joue en extérieur donc dans un
lieu magnifique la bd r mais en
extérieur ce qui est bien sûr oblige à
porter la voix davantage
donc en même temps ils sont dans un lieu
très porteur puisque c'est un lieu qui a
été construit en 1855 ou moins pour la
partie ancienne de la bibliothèque et du
coup dans un lieu que nanette aurait pu
voir voir construits à la fin de sa vie
et puis c'est sarda garriga qui harangue
la foule pour crier au peuple esclave il
est libre la nette fut déclaré libre à
l'abolition de l'esclavagé en 1848
mais faute de moyens elle fait le choix
de rester chez sa maîtresse
elles sont deux à jouer le rôle de
nanette orlan est l'une des deux
comédiennes présenté ce jour je vous le
donne le rôle de nanette l'année qu'eric
si l'esclave qui passent chez les
e-bonds et elle est affranchi en 1840
quand tu vite encore
et puis il y à la famille hibon
propriétaire de nanette joue le rôle
d'elizabeth c'est bon c'est la maîtresse
de nénette et sa famille et les abattis
bon et descendante de la famille blond
des gros propriétaires d'esclaves à la
réunion au xviiie siècle jouer il
s'appelle deguigné c'est la femme de
pierre de guinée est la fille de
elisabeth alors nanet m'a été donné
après la mort d'elizabeth et elle est
morte son invitation en lecteur
domestique grâce à la nette les
collégiens connaissent désormais une
partie de leur histoire
la période de l'esclavagé il n'avait
jamais abordé les détails pour mieux
comprendre les faits historiques
la professeur d'histoire géographie
s'est appuyé sur les recherches de
gilles gérard anthropologues et
historiens
j'ai été contacté par madame maçon à
partir d'un travail que j'ai fait qui
est en ligne sur les reconstitutions de
sa vie d'esclave et donc la famille
delhi le révolté de saint leu leu des
responsables et détaillées sur ce site
et on trouve parmi ses soeurs une
jeune fille qui s'appelle nanette et qui
va connaître l affranchissement de 1848
manette n'est pas n'importe qui elle est
la soeur délit qui prit la tête de la
révolte de saint leu en 1800 outre elie
et ses frères furent décapités de la
soeur délit peut- on connaît maintenant
la réunion un des chefs de la révolte de
1811 pas seulement lui trois autres
frères participe aussi à la révolte
madame
en avant
nanet morale à ou alors a vécu toute sa
vie cette liberté qui en réalité n'en
était pas une
nanet n'a pas su quoi en faire son
épitaphe imaginé par les collégiens de
bourbon lui redonne sa dignité d'être
humain
nanet n'aura jamais été libre de son
vivant désormais elle l'est pour
l'éternité